most Americans have a favorable view of  the police not surprising but that  doesn't mean they don't think that  they're a significant room for reform an  overwhelming number think that people  should be allowed to film police  officers there's little debate on that  issue and fully half of Americans think  that police officers are not held  accountable for police misconduct one of  the reasons this number may be so high  is that technology is making it possible  for Americans to be aware of these  events on a broader scale they're seeing  that these are how these things are  happening nationally rather than these  being isolated events